mientras el brillo de las vacaciones se
desvanece europa se enfrenta a una
oscura realidad en su lucha contra el
kobe 19 alemania superó los 40.000
fallecimientos por coronavirus el
domingo y la canciller angela merkel
advirtió de que lo peor está por llegar
hay una peligrosa segunda ola de la
pandemia en la que nuestro país está
como muchos otros en europa la semana
siguientes de invierno serán
probablemente la fase más difícil de la
pandemia cuando el reino unido está
apresurándose a vacunar para salir de la
crisis allí hay un número récord de
pacientes hospitalizados a medida que la
variante del virus eleva los contagios y
las muertes a niveles sin precedentes el
programa de vacunación nacional espera
inocular a unos 15 millones de personas
para mediados de febrero pero el
ministro de salud dice que llevará mucho
más tiempo
se le ofrecerá la vacuna a todos los
adultos para otoño absolutamente el
temporal está dificultando que españa
contenga el repunte de contagios post
navidad las grandes nevadas debidas al
filomena están bloqueando los accesos a
los hospitales y dificultando la
distribución de la vacuna facer este
lunes se cumple un año desde que china
confirmó la primera muerte por kobe 19
desde entonces se han registrado casi 2
millones de muertes a nivel global más
de 625.000 en europa